bonjour messieurs merci d'être avec nous
cet après midi sur rt france benoît
martin la mobilisation aujourd'hui aura
valeur de test dans les prochaines
semaines on évoque une rentrée sociale
chargée pour l'exécutif
oui dans l'effectif dans le discours du
président de république en date du 12
juillet à poser de graves difficultés ça
faisait des cils et une face divisions
dans le pays dans un même discours la
réforme des retraites delà
de la réforme relation chômage et fuit
également se passer les nerfs donc voila
c'était pas mal d'ingrédients qui
mobilise dans la rue et dans les
entreprises et des administrations
alors la cgt et pour la vaccination
attention on connaît un peu l'histoire
on sait que depuis 150 ans une auprès de
grands progrès sanitaires et d'hygiène
dans notre pays ça a permis de vivre
mieux et plus longtemps entre la
vaccination et les conduire vers le tout
à l'égout l'eau potable etc donc voilà
donc on est pour la vaccination des 5
contres 2 passes sanitaire car pour la
cgt ainsi vraiment une rupture d'égalité
on voit bien que dans les quartiers
populaires il n'y a plus de gens pauvres
de chômeurs de genre exclu c'est là que
les gens se vaccine le moins et donc il
faut de la conviction non plutôt que
d'aller il va vraiment des mesures
autoritaires il faute d'un conviction
c'est ce que dit vraiment nos
ordinations mondiale de la santé c'est
ce que dit le conseil de l'europe c'est
ce qu'on dit aussi à la cgt il faut de
la conviction de la science il faut
qu'un maximum de gens se vaccine parce
qu'il y en a marre de tous ces morts de
tous ses collègues au long de ces
collines le grave et on a marre
également d'autres atteintes liberté ce
sont des conflits au jeu
il fallait faire une vaccination
importante n'est pas par un contrat et
puis les employeurs c'est pas leur
boulot de faire du contrôle sanitaire
c'est tout un rôle régalien de l'état
non alors en alexandrins qu'est ce que
vous répondez à cela vous trouvez que
l'exécutif a manqué de conviction
en matière de pascal aubert d'abord
c'est pas très facile parce qu'il ya une
nuisance complotistes
principalement d'extrême droite mais
aussi venant la france insoumise qui
s'est opposé aux vaccins je me suis
félicité ces derniers jours et et j'ai
dis bravo à fabien roussel le président
du parti le patron du parti communiste
français qui a soutenu la vaccination au
moment où il ya des tendances anti dax
aix et anti science d'ailleurs
extrêmement sorte que des insoumis et
mélenchon a dit depuis un an des choses
parfois très hostile à la vaccination et
notamment aux vaccins arn messagers
alors que le parti communiste a toujours
soutenu la science comme il soutient les
télécoms moderne comme il soutient
nucléaire comme il soutient la
rationalité donc ce n'est pas facile de
savoir ce qu'il faut faire maintenant on
voit bien que le taux de vaccinations
nécessaires pour casser l'épidémie il
est malheureusement beaucoup plus
important avec le variant delta qu'avec
les les variants traditionnels je suis
comme tout le monde le pass annie terre
je trouve ça vraiment très casse
couilles mais pour pousser les gens à
aller à la vaccination
au moment où il faut un taux de
vaccination beaucoup plus fort pour
casser la dynamique du variant delta on
n'a pas beaucoup de solutions c'est pas
très simple ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'avant qu'on mette en place le pass
sanitaires le taux de vaccination qu'on
allait atteindre en france et être
totalement insuffisant pour arrêter le
variant delta donc oui c'est compliqué y
a pas de solution simple et puis et je
le répète ce n'est pas le cas du parti
communiste et de la cgt mais il ya eu
des mouvances
obscurantiste et anti vaccins très très
fortes qui ont convaincu une partie
significative de l'opinion qui ne se
font pas se faire vacciner notamment
venant venant de l'extrême droite et
plus particulièrement de l'extrême
droite catholique intégriste qui s'est
opposé à la vaccination
avec des arguments totalement
obscurantistes est totalement absurde
sur le plan scientifique mais qui ont
fait peur à une partie importante de la
population je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec le représentant de la cgt il faut
de la conviction il est absolument
essentiel de vacciner les gens dans les
quartiers où le taux de vaccination est
faible dans les minorités qui soit n'ont
pas accès facilement aux systèmes de
santé soit en peur à la vaccination et
on voit bien qu'il ya des communautés
qui ont très très peur de la vaccination
c'est le cas aux antilles où il ya un
pourcentage la population qui est très
important parmi les anti pacs et si vous
prenez les territoires et départements
d'outre-mer français vous avez un monde
entre les antilles où on est autour de
20 22 23 % de taux de vaccination et
puis saint pierre et miquelon où on
approche 90% de vaccination donc on a d
hétérogénéité entre les territoires qui
sont importantes et bien évidemment
qu'il faut aller vers les gens les plus
âgés les moins mobiles les plus
facilement atteignables par la
propagande obscurantiste et je le répète
qui vient un petit peu de l'extrême
gauche et des mets qui vient
principalement de l'extrême droite la
plus obscurantistes qui gangrène le
paysage politique français alors pour
revenir sur les propos de jean-luc
mélenchon a déclaré il ya quelques
semaines que ce vaccin obligatoire que
l'obligation vaccinale était une mesure
à ses yeux disproportionnée benoît
martin est ce que vous vous estimez que
l'exécutif a manqué mon toujours de
pédagogie ce qui explique que nous en
soyons ou huitième samedi de
mobilisation en france
c'est le manque de pédagogie depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire et puis il
ya eu tellement de mensonges qui ont été
dit par les premiers responsables en
denim des gouvernements haut depuis le
début on a tous en tête la sphère des
masses que les le tâtonnement autour des
tests les les retards vaccination et
nous beaucoup de choses qui pose
problème qu'il ya une crise de confiance
qui est très importante mais donc voila
moi je suis comme monsieur alexandre ans
c'est à dire que pour lui il n'est pas
question de soutenir les le complotisme
l'obscurantisme et d'antisémitisme qui
sévit dans pas mal de manifestations du
samedi donc la cgt et contre le pass
pour la vaccination il n'appelle pas aux
manifestations mais samedi sauf ici ou
là on peut avoir des syndicats
localement qui se sont réunis et voilà
rapport aux conséquences sont deux
concepts travail pense qu'il faut être
dans la rue il y avait quelques
comparaisons faites avec le mouvement
des gilet jaune a quitté également des
manifestations du samedi le jeu mais une
différence importante et je peux le voir
également si le relais les images que
mon rôle en ce moment en direct
chez les jets les gens s'étaient
beaucoup les gens qui étaient là pour
leur pouvoir d'achat mais franchement ça
se voyait alors c'était des gens de
condition modeste là quand même en vain
peu de gens de toutes conditions
sociales voilà et qui utilisa pour en
dire le passé ni cas comme prétexte pour
manifester sur autre chose c'est
beaucoup plus loin que le co2 passent
sanitaire scénarii simon certains contre
la vaccination certains sont dans une
logique tout à fait liberté reviennent
moi je veux bien qu'on soit libertaire
mais là la liberté libertarien c'est
tout à fait autre chose chacun ne fait
pas ce qu'il veut on vit en société il
ya des règles de vie commune je souhaite
que ces règles il adorait une manière la
plus démocratique possible de même que
je souhaite une démocratie sanitaire
mais dire je fais ce que je veux c'est
voir sa mère partie non je ne signe pas
tant pis pour les autres ça c'est pas
c'est tendu tout en rondeur du point vue
de la cgt pour être bien sûr de vous
comprendrez ce que vous voulez en venir
concernant les manifestants
d'aujourd'hui notamment vous ne
comprenez pas qu'il faut encore dans la
rue aujourd'hui c'est ça mais je
comprends qu'ils sont encore nombreux
dans la rue et moi j'approuve
dûment de mobilisation sur la question
du travail sur la restriction des
libertés sur les ruptures d'égalité et
donc les hospitaliers votre
manifestation et certains engrais lula
elles sont et réquisitionné puisque
l'espagnol reynes en général ils
continuent de travailler mais donc le 14
septembre à une journée d'action
justement d'en dire un mot cette
contrainte sociale que constitue le pass
sanitaires donc voilà si j'étais contre
le pass sanitaire mais nous ne
partageons pas une bonne partie des
arguments qui sont qui sont dits dans la
rue depuis plusieurs semaines à trois
derniers mois avec vous laurent
alexandre est ce qu il existerait ce
qu'il existe des alternatives
au pass annie terre c'est surtout la
vaccination est essentiellement la
vaccination à partir de la mort ou pour
des tas de raisons ne voulait pas
généraliser la vaccination obligatoire
on n'a pas beaucoup d'autres solutions
que pas sanitaires mais je voudrais
aller dans le sens de 2,2 du responsable
de la cgt la cgt ce que ce que l'on
observe aujourd'hui c'est que
globalement ce mouvement il est organisé
par des courants obscurantistes
d'extrême droite et les trois leaders
qui soutiennent principalement ce
mouvement c'est dupont aignan asselineau
et filippo c'est à l'extrême droite du
rassemblement national
on est au bout des ongles on est dans la
récupération je rappelle quand même
qu'il ya un an on a des vidéos de
filippo expliquant que le gouvernement
est trop laxiste et qu'il faut mettre en
place un confinement ultra dur et qu'il
faut tout bloquer la vidéo circule sur
youtube c'est ce que disait philippot il
ya il ya un an et aujourd'hui s'opposent
aux pas salutaire donc oui on est dans
de la récupération politicienne je pense
que filippo ne croient pas un mot de ce
qu'il raconte lors des manifestations et
là tout âge qu'il a constitué avec
toutes les droites extrêmes et les
catholiques intégristes les plus
obscurantistes franchement ce n'est pas
un mouvement progressif ce n'est pas un
mouvement de progrès on a là on a là une
récupération politique autour de
l'obscurantisme politique le pire
possible merci le temps nous manque on
aura l'occasion de poursuivre cet
échange merci à tous les deux laurent
alexandre essayiste et chirurgiens et
benoît martin secrétaire général de la
cgt paris merci à tous les deux